super pumped to be here thank you so so
much for giving a lot of thought about
what I wanted to talk about today super
excited about the QA and so with the
only 20 minutes I want to focus on
random things that are running through
my mind that I think could possibly
bring value to the audience so let's
start with number one up there I've
started articulating twenty years into
my career what I've actually been up to
like how did I get to this point I think
in a world right now where so many
people want to start talking about what
they're gonna do or who they're gonna be
or in a world where everybody's so
focused on building their personal brand
and I'm clearly an advocate of that and
have had the benefits but I want to tell
Amsterdam right now that I think an
important part of my narrative was for
the first 15 years of my business career
I didn't say a [ __ ] word to anybody I
went out and I worked 18 hours a day and
I built a liquor store into one of the
first e-commerce wine businesses in the
US and then in my mid-30s I decided that
I earned the right for the pleasure that
I have right now which is standing here
and I think one thing that I implore all
of you to give a lot of thought to is we
now live in a 24/7 content driven
snapchat Instagram build your personal
brand world it is massively important to
have something to talk about that is
authentic and not posturing and
peacocking to where you're going look we
are living through a very interesting
time we are living through a time where
over the last five to seven years we've
had an enormous growth of people that
are entrepreneurs right everybody's got
an idea right now in the marketplace and
every idea that's the uber for sneakers
is getting funded and what's really
interesting to me is we're about to go
into a period by show of hands how many
people in here are startups raise your
hands
cool so for about 10 to 15 percent of
you I I'm gonna make a very important
recommendation and take it for what it
is I really do believe that the dollars
that are being pumped
to the ecosystem if you look at it are
starting to dry up and I think that
we've lived through it's five to seven
year period where a lot of people have
built startups with the main focus of
raising the next round what they built
is financial arbitrage machines not
actual businesses so if you're one of
the 20% in this room right now I highly
recommend that you give a lot of thought
to starting converting your startup into
an actual business because if there's
not money your business goes out of
business and I think we've seen this two
or three times before and I think we're
starting to get into that ecosystem so I
highly highly recommend it I think I
think the thing that is really top of
mind for me right now that I want to
drill down here right now is attention
arbitrage I've been able to figure out
what I've actually been doing in 1996 my
atention arbitrage was actually
launching an e-commerce site instead of
opening a second liquor store I believe
that the internet was gonna be something
there's a lot of youngsters in here but
for everybody over 40 in this crowd you
remember this was a fad this was just a
little thing people had more disrespect
for the internet than they had for
snapchat a year ago so it was it was an
interesting period of time where most
people doubted my second arbitrage was
an email marketing in 1997 I had a
200,000 person email newsletter that had
91.3% open race how many people have
done email marketing in their career
those are bonkers [ __ ] numbers as you
know the reason that was though was not
because I was so great or Wine Library
was so great it was that nobody was
email marketing and so I moved quickly
and believed that over the next two to
five years people would use that medium
and that was the arbitrage my biggest
one that built my business was a company
called Google came out with something
called Adwords most people didn't know
what it was
I bought the word wine for five cents a
click and owned it for nine and a half
months before anybody bid me up this
before $0.10 was the minimum that was
obviously a very good thing and on and
on and on a lot of you became aware of
me for the first time when YouTube first
came out and again in 2006 most people
weren't thinking that YouTube was going
to become the Phenom
you know tomorrow KC's gonna talk or the
next day I mean people are building real
businesses and brands this was a decade
ago there was a video on YouTube when I
started Wine Library TV that had a
million views yet not one not one video
on the platform so it was a small
platform everybody thought it was stupid
there was no advertising but it was the
first time that I understood that
content could drive business I was just
you know as some of you might remember
and I just sat in front of a camera for
20 minutes at a time
drinking four bottles of wine right and
hundreds of thousands of people thought
that was interesting enough and I was
educating it was also the first time in
my career that I felt the effects of
what has now been the foundation of what
I've tried to do over the last decade
and it is probably my biggest
recommendation to this room today and
this is probably good human being advice
not just entrepreneur and startup an
investor advice what I learned from Wine
Library TV is the following the true
story of Wine Library TV was the day
that I thought I was gonna start it I
thought I was gonna do something similar
to QVC and I I don't know if you have a
QVC or Shopping Network in Europe but
QVC in America it's a show and they sell
stuff through the TV I thought I was
gonna do the QVC of wine the first
episode of that show when that camera
went on and that light went on I
realized that this was going to be on
the internet forever and that I didn't
want to just peddle wine I decided I
wanted to be a value to people in
learning about wine because I was scared
that if I was peddling something I
didn't believe in that somebody would
come up to me at a party and say do you
like this and I'd say no I hate it
they're like well you [ __ ] said it
was awesome online Liberty you're a scam
artists I'm like [ __ ] no so I was very
focused on leveling up and I really
believe the one great piece of advice if
you want to take anything from this talk
as we have to start realizing that
giving and doing things in business
without expectation of return from the
other individual is probably the
greatest leverage that you could ever
deploy in your business life though it
is extremely rare in today's business
environment and it has absolutely been
the bedrock of what has allowed me to
win all my engagement all my selfies
right over there in signing books
all the content I have nothing to sell I
have a book that I [ __ ] sell once
every three years for thirteen dollars
this is not about monetizing an audience
it's about building leverage to build
brand versus sales one of the biggest
things that I see going on right now in
digital media is that we don't have a
lot of people doing branding and
marketing we have a lot of people doing
sales the reason so many of you were
confused by the value of snapchat is
because in the digital landscape we now
think transactional everything is about
what's the ROI of every piece of content
every single action what's the last
attribution what's the conversion rates
it's all become math based and that's
fine because I love sales more than
anybody but I promise you these [ __ ]
guys
Nike then he tagged me on a browser and
then rekey me and then travel all over
the internet and pound me with banner
ads until I gave up and bought it I
bought it because they [ __ ] marketed
to me over the last twenty years and I
don't even [ __ ] know why I buy it and
that is a very important point because
what we're living through is a time
where people are just being very
transactional and conversion based when
everything continues to get arbitrage
another thought that I'm curious how
many people here have gone to the life
that I've gone to over the last three
months I no longer have a laptop or an
iPad I now only live through my mobile
device how many people are on that level
doing that raise your hands not a lot
and this is like think about this
conference I really think that this
trend I do believe that if I came back
here in two years that 50 40 30 percent
of the hands in this room would go up to
that following question and I'm
completely fascinated by it and then for
everybody in the room that is building
businesses on the internet the thought
of what's happening in your landing page
optimization or the UI and UX of your
product in a desktop environment I think
is in the beginning stages of being
disrupted and that's what I really spent
most of my time in which is what's the
attention arbitrage where do I think
your eyes and ears are gonna be before
you do and how do I go in land grab and
buy up that property and how do I then
deploy and build the best houses on that
property through
content that is the pattern of my career
in 2006 I thought this social media
thing was gonna be really big and in
2007-2008 I laid my foundation and by
2007 and 8 I invested in Facebook and
Tumblr and Twitter and things of that
nature and I did quite well I also used
them to tell my story sell my wine do my
thing I think this is super important to
understand because I think we also
decide that things are emerging too fast
this is not just being first mover a lot
of people like to give me credit like
you predicted all this stuff you were
sorry I just want to be on the record
forever there's plenty of people here
recording I have been predicted [ __ ]
I'm not Nostradamus what I've done well
is I've moved quickly once you actually
started using them I didn't predict
Twitter I wasn't right about snapchat I
was just looking at data snapchat two
years ago when I first started talking
about it already had tens of millions of
users there was real people using it I'm
not predicting anything I'm paying
attention there's probably very few
people in this room that are paying as
much attention to anchor2 peach to all
these platforms as I am but I'm not
putting all my content or all my time
and I'm also not crippled by putting my
time and effort into platforms before
they have a hundred or 200 million users
for example how many of you remember
that five minutes four years ago where
Socialcam got big raise your hand all
right so three nerds Socialcam got big
for three minutes because of the
Facebook newsfeed juiced it and I had a
lot of users and it was hot for four
months six months I used it feverishly
and used it a lot it collapsed and meant
nothing but during that period I learned
so much about mobile video and the
cadence of it and how people interacted
with it that when vine came along a year
and a half later and then Instagram
video and then snapchat I'd already put
in the work and had the learnings from
human behavior that I deployed against
the next thing there are way too many
people in this room that do not do
actions because they're crippled by the
short-term results versus what it means
in the long term and this goes to market
and this goes to running your business
and this comes down to what I probably
want to spend a few more minutes on
right now which is my friends there's a
lot of people in here that are startup
founders that should not be my friends
there are a lot of people in here that
work at agencies that should not be they
should be probably switched and vice
versa and different things one of the
things that is absolutely driving me
right now in my life is the untold
depression the untold suicides to just
get dark for a second it's not fun to
talk about but it's important we are
lacking self-awareness in this space in
a very substantial way and there's a lot
of people that are about to be met with
a lot of disappointment and are
struggling how many people are an
entrepreneur in here raise your hand you
guys and gals know this isn't easy
there's nobody else it's fun to work for
somebody you know why you get to blame
the boss she and he is an [ __ ] not
you when you're an entrepreneur where
there's nobody else behind you it's on
you and one thing we're not talking
about is the level of success everybody
thinks they have to build [ __ ] uber
everybody thinks they have to make
millions of dollars
it's unbelievable what we've done and I
absolutely want to make sure that we're
starting to have real conversations
making $100,000 a year 100 euros that's
massively successful we need to
recalibrate what success looks like in
our space because we're forcing through
the branding of what we're doing very
impractical very high-risk very low
return results for so many because
everybody's shooting for 10 billion what
guys there's like four apps that big
there's like uber and Instagram like how
many [ __ ] billion dollar companies do
you think there are and so I really am
passionate about starting to reframe the
conversation about the number one thing
that I have noticed in my 20 years of my
success because let me tell you
something I suck [ __ ] at almost
everything what I've done well is I've
deployed self-awareness around what I am
and I know what I am and there's a lot
of things I wish I was seven years ago
as a lot of you know I
plenty of leverage in the web 2.0 social
media movement I was one of the guys I
was one of the 20 most follow people on
Twitter I didn't go and raise 40 million
dollars to build the next Facebook I
didn't raise 50 million dollars to build
a platform around wine
I was self-aware enough even though I
had all the opportunity in the world to
build product that I wasn't gonna be
successful seven years ago I went out
and built a boring digital agency right
I built something practical all my
internet friends a lot of the people
gonna be on the stage they made fun of
me like why don't you go build a big
company or something grand I built what
I knew I could build I'm very proud that
over the last four years I've grown
vaynermedia from three to a hundred
million dollars a year in revenue not
[ __ ] valuation
and cool great that's fine and who gives
a [ __ ] what I'm Way more worried about
than what I've done is what you're gonna
do
I implore you my friends this is fancy
first of all this is unbelievable this
is one of the nicest set up still
conference I've ever seen let's clap it
up for these guys it's unbelievable
right there's like there's like [ __ ]
food trucks it's like sunny and [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] awesome anyway what I
did well was I just didn't give a [ __ ]
when I when I called I'm 40 when I grew
up in in the United States like being a
good student
was the big thing I was making $3,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards and
getting D's and F's and everybody
thought I was a loser like that's what
the narrative was now it's reversed if I
was in school now making three four
thousand dollars a weekend as a 13 year
old I would have been the next big thing
right I went through it and I did not
succumb to the current thing that
everybody thought in America was the
right thing which was go to the best
school you could go to I understood who
I was and I went in all in on my
strengths and I implore a lot of you to
do that there's too many people sitting
in this room that want to be the number
one ceo/founder
but if you were the seventh employee of
a company you know I'd much rather be
number forty-one at Facebook than number
one of Facebook and so I think we're
seeing that and so I'd like to stand up
here and I'd like to say look there's a
lot of things that I wish I was
different at as a matter of fact back to
what I'm let's be very meta right now do
you know that I wish I didn't curse on
stage do you know many people don't
share my content don't like me because
of it I wish I didn't do it I just can't
be anything that I'm not and so I
implore you don't worry about what's
cool right now or what we're all focused
on or what your mama wants you to be you
need to go home from this conference
you'll be inspired there'll be cool
people there's an interesting [ __ ] but
I'm telling you with the bottom of my
heart it is fundamentally irrelevant if
you don't know who the [ __ ] you are and
the quicker you can start forcing
yourself to understanding what role you
play number
number seven PR marketing product you
are everybody wants to be somebody else
I wish I was the quarterback of the New
York Jets it's not gonna happen and so
if I can accomplish one and by the way
I'm being very realistic I'll be very
very transparent with you this little
seven minute rant that I just came up
with I'm trying to reach one person like
I'm this is not so easy it's hard to
have the ego and the humility at equal
ends to figure yourself out but I
promise you as I've looked across the
landscape and I've looked at 25 50
thousand startups at this point right I
have now spent the last four years of my
life with the Toyotas and the Pepsi's
and the gee you know biggest brands in
the world myself my inner circle the one
connection point from corporate America
to startup to VC to personalities the
one connection point is self-awareness
once you start understanding yourself
once you start actually executing on who
you actually are versus who you wish you
were things start to change very quickly
and so the reason I'm passionate about
this is this is always very worldly
advice and has probably historically
always good things to talk about I just
feel that if any of you really paid
attention to the macroeconomic
infrastructure of what's happening in
our space right now this Nirvana
that we've lived through for the last
six or seven years is about to shift it
just is it's just the data I don't want
it I wish it was Nirvana forever just
like everybody else during the down
cycles the people that are able to win
are the ones that are most in tune with
themselves the ones that are the most
practical so again to make this valuable
to you in this room number one if your
startup please start understanding how
you're gonna make money as soon as
possible you're running a business
you're running a business businesses
need to make money especially when
there's no money to fund you based on
your last valuation number two as a
human being sitting at this conference
this is all very encompassing and very
exciting but start chipping away against
what you think you want and start really
looking at what you bring to the table
because the quicker you figure that out
the more successful you will have and
number three please start understanding
how to provide value without expectation
in return it is unbelievable to me how
many people already tonight we've seen
for five minutes seven eight people
giving me something as they think but
really expecting something in return for
that give humans can feel that it's not
the way to go and we really need to
start thinking about that and number
four understand the following and this
is very ironic given my concerns about
where the markets going I'll end with
this in lieu of all of that this whole
thing that we're living through has just
started the consumer web is only twenty
years old
Windows 95 kind of started this thing
the internet thing is very new
everything that we all talked about
didn't exist ten years ago over the next
10 years the biggest companies in the
world from Europe and Asia and us from
anywhere in the world because we are now
at scale the biggest companies in the
world are going to be created over the
next 20 years from zero there are people
sitting in this room right now that are
gonna build the next major company and
so we are also blessed that we are
actually human beings during this period
where there is so much upside so much
opportunity and so everything I've
talked about when you parallel on the
obnoxious opportunity and land grab an
opportunity if you're able to wire those
two things together I think a lot of
good stuff could happen for you and I'd
like that for you I'd like that a lot
thank you
you